ils sont une douzaine dans la salle mais
plus d'une soixantaine en ligne à
chercher la faute aux rares parmi plus
de 250 lots mis aux enchères des images
qui nous emmène en afrique ou dans le
japon de la seconde moitié du 19e siècle
grâce à des pionniers ces gens là
étaient les photographes étaient d'abord
des explorateurs quand on sait comment
il fallait emmener son matériel
photographique on n'avait pas un
téléphone qui faisait appareils photos
en même temps il fallait des caisses et
des caisses de matériel parmi le
matériel ancien des chambres noires et
des plaques certaines étaient utilisés
dans un procédé antérieure aux négatifs
photos est aujourd'hui quasiment disparu
le daguerréotype donc en fait il ya deux
procédés différents un procédé qui va
devenir le procédé général de la
photographie le posséder négatif positif
avec une amélioration de la technique
des négatifs et un procédé de
photographie unique le daguerréotype qui
appelait chez des pièces exceptionnelles
comme cette plaque de 1845 montrant une
vue de lyon elle a été vendue à 8500
euros mais la pièce maîtresse c'est cet
album d' edouard baldus le photographe
préféré de napoléon iii un album
commandés par la compagnie de chemin de
fer paris lyon méditerranée
il a dû être parfaitement conservés il
ya pour ainsi dire aucune mur aucune
rousseur les photos sont dans un état de
contrastes superbe les 69 photos
semblent en effet avoir été prise de nos
jours alors qu'elle date du milieu du
19e siècle et les connaisseurs ne s'y
trompe pas un acheteur étranger a
remporté l'album pour 52 mille euros